hey guys notice anything different about
my face it's the fact that I'm smiling
because I'm so excited about today's
topic
Hollywood's obsession with remakes are
there any remakes that are better than
the original what's the worst remake of
all time we have a super cool panel here
to give us the straight poop he is the
badass in chief at badass digest Devin
Faraci hi everybody
you can hear him on his hilarious
podcast Jordan Jessie go Jordan Morris
where do I look to say hello oh you just
did great before we start hammering
remakes which is really easy
what's a remake that you have fondness
for you know I was saying this to you
before is it it's weird would even
remake even is anymore because my
favorite movie of all time since I work
at badass digest is with the Wizard of
Oz and it really is it honestly is it's
the best movie ever made depending on
how we're defining it it's a remake
because there had been a silent version
of the movie made previously so is that
really a remake going back to the same
material twice can be a pretty good
thing uh Jordan let me ask you what's a
what's a remake that you're a fan of one
of my favorite remakes and I think in
really underrated remake is the death
race remake starring Jason Statham the
70s remake stars David Carradine and
Sylvester Stallone so it's a silly movie
and it's pretty fun to watch but the new
one they really like take the premise of
car battling seriously I got to disagree
wholeheartedly on that okay nothing the
original is so much fun because the
premise isn't about Knisley car battles
it's the idea that you're on a
cross-country race and part of the point
is to run pedestrians over along the way
so they have a point system that is like
literally like 30 points for babies over
75 years old has been upped to 100
points there's a hospital and they bring
all their old people out into the middle
of the street to get rid of them
whenever the death race comes so there's
a line of old people in wheelchairs
daddies do it now now that you mention
it I think you may have talked me out of
it I think the desperate inmate could
have used more elderly murder I want to
bring up a remake that I'm a huge fan of
The Departed
which is a remake of the Hong Kong
action movie Infernal Affairs
I had been hearing from people oh it's
superior to the departed I disagree I I
actually agree I like the departed
better than Infernal Affairs I think
infernal pairs is really good it's a
tight story it's really well-constructed
well told but it seems like just the
mini version of The Departed which has a
lot more resonance a lot more character
development I'm not the [ __ ] rat okay
I'm not the [ __ ] rat let's think if
you have the the greatest living
director remaking a movie it's probably
gonna be a pretty good remake another
remake I'd like to throw out there a
girl with the Dragon Tattoo
they didn't want it to be called a
remake it seems like a remake it seems
like this very much the same with me you
know it seems like anything I think this
is a good this is a good point is that I
think sometimes when remakes bite it
it's because they are just shot-for-shot
remake a case in point
psycho starring Vince Vaughn I think we
can all agree that's maybe one of the
worst remakes of all time well Devon you
had some thoughts on was a terrible
movie but I really like what's being
done there is that it almost feels like
a punk-rock statement about how dumb all
this stuff is it's almost like a
prophecy for like the era of remakes
that was to were to come and it was like
they're all gonna be really maddeningly
similar and they're not not ever gonna
be as good
what would either of you throw out there
as the worst remake ever star trek into
darkness Ellie's movie make of wrath
yeah there are some who will argue this
on a remake but I think that it fits
most of the parameters of the same
characters it recreates scenes it goes
through all the same motions matically
it has a lot of the same beats it's
essentially the same movie all over
again yeah go ahead and head off some
Star Trek nerd technically it's in a
parallel universe at universe if you
will yeah because when the Romulans okay
sorry
I'd had to do that compared to Ricardo
Montalban I feel like Cumberbatch didn't
chew the scenery enough nice big
yeah I think that a lot of times when
people remake a movie they don't want to
be seen as being campy cuz obviously
there's something you hapless movies
that we love there can't be Death Race
Wrath of Khan there's some like great
hilarious over-the-top stuff I think
people are so scared of being can't be
they forget to have fun and I think that
the battery makes are the ones that are
just no fun well I think we're finally
coming back into a period where people
are not afraid to have fun again
I like the Marvel movies a lot because
they're fun nobody has to like you know
be like depressed the whole movie we can
have a good time it can still be serious
but it's colorful and it's fun Jordan
any remakes that you're looking forward
to yeah um I think so I'm cautiously
optimistic about the Godzilla remake
coming up yeah there hasn't been a bad
one of those in our life oh wow yes
there was a terrible one Oh
Godzilla got killed by two planes the
world's most fearsome monster here's the
coolest thing I've heard about the movie
so far it's gonna be a plot where
Godzilla fights another monster and I
think we haven't seen that in a long
time from Godzilla I mean I sense in
cific room in Japan yeah I don't not
just history for yourself when are we
gonna get a monsters fighting each other
those were robots how oops it's more fun
when they're fighting other money we're
technically mechs because robots are
autonomous and mechs run by people I'm
just saying you the internet'll yeah a
couple episodes we've never seen
Evangelion
Devin you did another one that you want
to mention well we live in weird times
where we can have two remakes of the
same movie happening in our lifetimes
and yeah the Tim Burton Planet of the
Apes remake which is a piece of crap
yeah great dismal and then we have a
Rise of the Planet of the Apes which I
liked a lot yeah really found its way to
incorporate elements of the mythology
I'm a huge Planet of the Apes nerd yeah
I really like the movie but a lot of
people would say rise to the Planet of
the Apes is a prequel how I'm gonna have
to get real nerdy on you right now owner
- technically Rise of the Planet of the
Apes is a remake of conquest of the
Planet of the Apes the fourth film in
the ape series and there had a sequel
coming darn it the Planet of the Apes
which I'm really excited about yeah it's
a remake of the worst plan of the Apes
movie I loved about uh huh and that's
what you should be remaking the bad
movies the ones I had a good idea take
that and make it better and that's what
they're hopefully doing with dawn of the
Planet of the Apes
I'm really excited for that that kind of
opens up like wire why do you do a
remake it seems like something like a
Red Dawn it's hot young it people just
in a vehicle that'll make money it's
because Hollywood is so broken right now
the executives get to say well the
original Red Dawn is a cultural
touchstone and when the movie flops they
get to go I don't know we all thought it
was a good idea because everybody loves
the original and so it's this way of
handing off blame it's a way of playing
it safe and cheap and it's it's just
their their their cowardly kids that's
why that's why they're happening
you've heard of here Hollywood hourly
[ __ ] unless you want to remake
tremors which I would love to see what
is your favorite remake of all time
leave an answer in the comment section
below
best answer gets a screen junkies
t-shirt I want to thank my super cool
panel Devin Faraci badass digest Jordan
Morris Jordan Jessie go by the way guys
I'm growing this formidable mustache in
support of Movember and their men's
health awareness campaign to learn more
about it check out Movember calm I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter thanks for
watching bye bye The Incredible Hulk
returns the TV movie from the 80s that
is cheesy and terrible Thor looks like
he got his hammer at Home Depot